Jaguars new tagline is good to be bad
and you can see some of that aggression
inside the new XF sedan its arched
haunches smooth body and feline nose
make me want to jump in and get it
purring like a wildcat
starting at just over fifty thousand
dollars Jaguar makes the XF for those
who want something different from the
standard BMW 3 series or the Mercedes
e-class both of which outsell the XF by
tens of thousands of cars each year this
sedan is for daily drivers who want to
be seen as a little elevated with a
little more personality than the normal
mass luxury options
well driving this car is fun it feels
comfortable but not casual a lot of
luxury sedans lull you to sleep this
doesn't it makes you feel like you want
to engage with the road on the XF you
can choose between three different
engines all have a velvet smooth 8-speed
automatic transmission with paddle
shifting i love that the steering
automatically adjusts to your drive
style and to road conditions the
suspension is what you'd expect from a
luxury sedan to its alert but not overly
so and the brakes are reassuringly
responsive one thing you will notice
when you drive it is the start step
technology that cuts the engine the
moment you come to a standstill it's a
little disconcerting at first you can
disengage the function with the push of
a button but it does improve efficiency
the interior smells like a saddle shop
the fine leather grain seats are
complemented by rosewood and brushed
matte silver trim the 7-inch touchscreen
in the center is simple to use I was
happy to use the power sunroof on a warm
sunny day those sunny days are perfect
for showing off to get a load of those
coy dual hood vents sterling lattice
grill and the 20-inch rims I mean just
look at it this cat is ready to play
you